لطالما كانت ملفات المفقودين من ضمن
القضايا الشائكه والمعقده التي ترافق كل
نزاع حول العالم حيث ان عمليه التقصي
والبحث قد تستمر لسنوات او عقود طويله دون
فائده في السودان تحديدا ومع تواصل الحرب
بين المكونين العسكريين تتلقى فرق البحث
التابعه للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
اتصالات دائمه للابلاغ عن حالات فقدان
واختفاء لافراد في العائلات السودانيه
اللجنه قالت بانه لا توجد ارقام دقيقه
للمفقودين في السودان ذلك ان الجهات
الرسميه هي المخوله في تقديم المعلومات
والمعطيات الدقيقه حول اعداد المفقودين
الا ان ذلك ليس متاحا حاليا بسبب تواصل
القتال الذي خلف بدوره شللا كبيرا على
القطاع الصحي
تواجه صعوبات كبيره جدا في التشغيل الطبي
كل المستشفيات والمؤسسات اللي هي كانت
موجود فيها دعم السريع واتخذك سكنات ما
زالت خارج الخدمه خرابه الاربعين مستشفى
اضف لذلك ما زالت هنالك بعض الاعتداد
المتاخره تمت في الاسبوع الماضي
من جهتها نقابه اطباء السودان قالت ان عدد
القتل المدنيين منذ بدايه الصراع ارتفع
الى نحو 958 شخصا واضافت ان جميع مستشفيات
الجنينه بدار فورد خارج الخدمه والوضع بات
كارثيا الارقام الامميه اكدت ايضا ان فرار
قرابه 200 الف شخص من السودان ونزوح حوالي
مليوني شخص بينهم اكثر من 476 الفا عبروا
الى دول الجوار وفق المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره التابعه للامم المتحده المتحدث
الاقليميه للجنه للجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر ايمان طرابلسي قالت ان هناك
اشكاليات كبيره تواجه عمل اللجنه في
السودان ابرزها عدم قدره السلطات المحليه
والجهات الصحيه الرسميه على تسريع عمليه
التعرف على هويات الجثامين واضافت انه لا
يزال هناك
الكثير من الجيتامين مجهوله الهويه ما
يصعب عمليه التوثيق والتاكد منهيه
المفقودين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات